okay welcome back you know whether
you're eating or cooking the holidays
means a lot more time in the kitchen and
as you get ready to make another big
meal this weekend it really is important
to stay safe Candace Charles joining us
live this morning from the Southwest Gas
model home with some reminders Candace
good morning to you
good morning to you good morning folks
now washing your hands washing off
counters cutting boards utensils after
use to prevent contamination and also
just not leaving your food unattended
when you're cooking those are some
simple cooking safety tips we can all
remember but what are a few that we
can't keep track of I have Stephen
Miller here of Southwest Gas with me to
answer that question thank you so much
for joining us now one that comes to
mind is those silent dangers while
cooking what are those well if you're
going to be in the kitchen using your
oven and your your stovetop for the oven
there's some simple rules to follow that
will ensure that your oven is working
efficiently and keeping you safe the
first one is make sure that you when
your oven is in use keep the door shut
okay you do not want to use this as a
space heater to try to heat up the house
that is not what it's intended for ovens
only work efficiently if the door is
sealed shut another one is do not put
aluminum foil at the bottom them you see
that's kind of common oh that's a good
one I never really thought about that
one it'll actually smother the Flames
which could lead to some CO2 so it's an
easy fix just just don't uh put aluminum
foil down there and thirdly uh if your
oven has a broiler or storage down here
make sure that if it's a broiler you
know it's a broiler and don't try to
store any items down there that could
cause a fire all right simple enough
Stephen thank you so much we appreciate
it and of course we got you covered with
all of these tips in details on our
website eightnewsnow.com for now Candace
Claus has it covered with all the
details I'm live from the Southwest Gas
model home
toss it back to you guys in the studio
all right Candace thank you very much
you just blew both of our minds with the
foil I know the foil a lot of people do
have Candace that's really good advice I
had no idea thanks we've learned
something today we learned something new
thank you